big news
in the 2022 scene Beto O'Rourke has a
huge endorsement he was just endorsed by
Harry Styles
the pop singer which means that Beto
O'Rourke has an absolute lock on the men
who wear dresses vote birds of a feather
flock together so it is no surprise that
Beto who has been known to Don some
ladies garments now and again would have
a lock on Harry Styles who I think is
entirely stopped wearing pants
only wear his dresses no surprise also
that Harry Styles would endorse Beto
Harry Styles is a huge lib he is a big
gun control proponent he's done work
with every town which is one of the
left-wing gun control groups he's worn a
pride flag as clothing and now he's
supporting Beto okay does this really
move the needle very much
I don't know I don't live in Texas I
have a lot of friends from Texas
and I don't think an endorsement from
Harry Styles is exactly going to swing
that race you're seeing a lot of
desperation out of that race in
particular because Beto now is just a
multi-election loser
he was a pretty much unremarkable member
of the House of Representatives then he
runs for president and loses and and he
was so celebrated when he launched his
campaign glossy covers a Vanity Fair and
then he went absolutely nowhere then he
decided he was going to run against Ted
Cruz for the senate in Texas that again
didn't go anywhere now he's running for
governor it just looks sad it looks
really really sad the people just don't
want him right now you got to go to
establishtitles.com Knowles because I
tell you there was a period when I felt
like I wasn't getting no respect no
respect I tell you and then that all
changed thanks to established titles now
I Am Lord Michael Knowles and you can be
a lord or a lady as well you can get the
respect that you deserve all you need is
a one square foot plot of land in
Scotland established titles is a Project
based on an historic Scottish custom
where landowners are referred to as
Lance
or Lords and Ladies in English in your
title pack you will be bestowed with at
least one square foot of dedicated land
on a private estate in edelston Scotland
plus an official certificate with a
Crest your certificate features a unique
plot Number with which you can see the
exact location of your land title packs
from established titles are a fun and
unique gift for any occasion there are
even couple packs because you don't want
to be a Lord and then your poor wife
doesn't get to be a lady with your
certificate you could officially add the
prefix Lord or lady to your credit cards
plane tickets even your dating profiles
a plus established titles commits to
preserving The Woodlands not only in
Scotland but around the planet
they've got Partnerships with global
Charities like one tree planted and
trees for the future to help with our
afforestation efforts and for every
order they receive a tree is planted
established titles told me get this
first 200 people purchasing a title pack
using my exclusive link will receive a
plot within a few walking minutes of
mine that's right so depending on how
many of you want to become a lord or a
lady we can build our own kingdom and
that will be a wonderful and it will be
run with an iron fist established titles
is actually running a massive sale right
now if you use code Knolls you'll get on
top of that an additional 10 off go to
established titles.com get your gifts
right now and help support the channel
speaking of narrative
the the Democrats are losing control of
the narrative
I think Beto and a lot of the other Dems
are headed for defeat in November
because the Democrat policies are
failing The Narrative is not matching
reality people are catching on to that
and the Democrats have no answers there
was such an embarrassing moment
yesterday at the White House poor Karine
Jean-Pierre hardest job in the world and
she's not up to it even if it weren't
the hardest job in the world Karine
Jean-Pierre was asked about the gas
prices because you see the Biden
Administration took a lot of credit when
the gas prices went down but what
happens when gas prices go up again
you've said the president was
responsible for gas prices coming down
is the president responsible for gas
prices going up
so it's a lot more nuanced than that
right Peter you know this you know this
Peter there's a lot when when good stuff
happens it's very simple we're
responsible when bad stuff happens
though Peter it's very nuanced and
complicated
this is pretty sad this is what happens
when you hear this especially in
Academia
whenever these Eggheads in Academia
don't have an answer for something they
say well it's very problematic
it's problematic and nuanced you see
there's no there's so many sides to this
issue
no well what is it either the President
is responsible for gas prices or he's
not
you you could even say that gas prices
are complicated and the president has
some influence over them but doesn't
have total influence over them you could
say that world events dictate gas prices
much more than the president but the
president still can do certain things
fine whatever but what you can't say is
that the President is responsible when
the prices go down but not responsible
when the prices go up
you just can't say that they're right
either the president affects gas prices
or not the degree to which he affects
them
is the same when the prices go up and
when the prices go down but they have no
answer for that and and so they just
keep spinning their wheels I don't think
that persuades anybody speaking of
pushing these narratives speaking of
everything every single thing becoming
super duper gay
we have got a a trailer for this movie
that my producers insist that I watch
it's called Bros it's a movie it didn't
do very well apparently at the box
office on opening weekend it's
apparently very very gay
they The Producers want to know if I
should review this movie give an actual
proper review we'll take a look at the
trailer together you tell me if we
should review the movie the rest of the
show is continuing now you don't want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]